you're welcome to this video playing
aqaba in the house Austrian flag to try
a French the delayed exchange hmm yeah
not the kind of line that makes you very
excited okay I'm trying to exchange the
bishop 105 let's see if I can manage
oops playing my g 3 yeah if he wants to
control f5 that's clear still h3 is
often played for some reason I think
I can maybe go edge ravaged for it and
at first I need to get the King out of
this age five is we could have taken
Bishop g4 energies and so okay he
prevented this idea how do i get to get
the exchange going or should I play some
more prep moves like King be eight or
something that's a bit slow could also
try to get the night here over to see 42
the 6 and then play something to f5
maybe maybe try that
I managed to exchange some some minor
pieces especially the bishop on d6
against the bishop on d3 i'm i'm in good
shape this is the main num teejah claim
that i have splaying if before i could
play a 505 fixing the pawn let's do that
interesting this I didn't expect but ok
maybe push or maybe a Knight to f4 nitro
for us not really not really terribly
dangerous ok still the g7 porn is
hanging can play we cook here you should
page 7 book age eight it's not
particularly helpful Bishop interesting
Bishop f5 he's got rookie son ok the
idea is to play night see ATM and I'd c8
all night f4 I have fun bishop I know I
don't have this number five hmm maybe
neither for now Bishop at five still
lucky seven
and interesting yeah maybe you should go
neither for now it's hard for me to not
allow the capture babies tried on
calculating some technical things
neither for looks like a move that just
secure some edge if he manages to take
only six also always need to take with
the pawn and this is this is really weak
pawn on d6 so I'm not quite sure why is
not going either form it's a simple but
good solution yeah this I didn't expect
not saying that it is bad but I didn't
expect it ok maybe I really yeah I'm
able to play Knight b6 and grab this
pawn or a four I think I needed to play
this anyway this night is under fire
from the bishop and maybe a night f4 I
can
maybe play Bishop f5 maybe i can not
quite sure Wow ah because the the night
is actually actually protected I didn't
really didn't really pay any attention
to that okay so let's kick it back and
now the g7 is hanging okay yeah yeah he
can maybe really take it and hot the
same
maybe you can take it okay I'm trying
for some play here attacking a form I
don't really see a good move to to keep
it protected maybe I could have played
f6 something like that but it doesn't
look right maybe Wow take only for I
don't know okay let's just take first
and think later no it's grabbing
interesting I thought that also Bishop
h3 would be am a possible idea and then
shrine for work age group g8 for the pin
come on let's gamble on that I don't
really have time to to calculate things
hmm it's at least a very tricky position
he also has this weird intermediate move
looks lucky 7 but don't think it's so
great yeah at least it has irritated him
also not so easy to move now and you can
play all kinds of stuff taking on c4
yeah this weird movie seven of course
just take the bishop home didn't take
the bishop but I have Luke g8 now right
why not come on up kick it okay and
Bishop g4 i also have 92 more this kind
of moves ok i'll take this first the
night on a 4 it's not helping and maybe
Knight e5 is a move that will help me ok
if I if I manage to get to age for then
he's very close to being mated ok let's
try that Queen the a to H form Queen
edge for now is playing f3 maybe ok take
it first
hooha didn't I expect that but it's no
direct mate let's have threatened made
first and then see what's going on can
take f3 now let's let's do that 22
seconds and this is in fact the most
problematic time morning really check
this one this is Jamie checkmate black
I'm a bit did stunts here too funny mate
but I'm not sure he could have played
king a king f2 and I don't don't see him
made down I thought Queen h2 is
basically the same thing but okay I
thought this one at least is the strap
with night h1 am i winning here I'm I
don't check not quite sure ok this is
easy check check Nate so he needs to go
to his three and then okay rook e8 is
what I what I saw but I wasn't sure that
it's lifted leads to a maid here wow wow
that's cool the winning move is Queen d2
check Queen takes Andrew cage form and
this I would have never found check
check and where's the measure checkmate
wow what to move 22 is the only move the
twins problem
yeah no chance that they would have
found that very lucky that that he took
on chat each one the knowing the major
in to make snake Wow the N factum the
computer wants to take on edge for now
with probability law and this is yeah
this is losing due to exactly this line
the vision kavita wants to play this
which is essentially the same thing and
here i don't have any other more slides
just need to give the checks and can i
change that check and always I always
have need to need to work to check and I
cannot cannot allow look aged aid mate
ok yeah this is actually a witness well
Jack getting all this was check now I
have time for c6 and have my king secure
after the queen is gone I can mr. sepan
wow very very funny game at the end I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching